wieder damit gedroht jetzt hat erdogan
es getan
die grenzen zur eben zu öffnen entweder
wir werden diesen menschen in ihrer
heimat ein würdiges leben ermöglichen
oder alle werden ihren anteil an dieser
last tragen müssen
da ist er wieder der böse erdogan
instrumentalisiert flüchtlinge erpresst
die ihnen so weit so schlecht und europa
küsschen und 700 millionen hier
tränengas und wasserwerfer dort auch
gummigeschosse werden wohl eingesetzt
bei der verteidigung der europäischen
wertegemeinschaft verletzte gibt es die
türkei spricht von einem toten
flüchtlinge die griechen dementieren
wenn jetzt die außengrenzen der
europäischen union nicht geschützt
werden könnte dann ist diese grundidee
einer europäischen asylpolitik in der
zukunft geändert an der griechischen
grenze ist sie heute schon beendet athen
setzt vier wochen das asylrecht aus
geflüchtete werden umgehend an die
türkische grenze zurück gebracht ihr hab
und gut konfisziert
wir waren schon zwei mal drüben aber sie
haben uns wieder zurückgeschickt
sie haben uns beschimpft unsere handys
und unser geld weggenommen sogar meine
schuhe
auf den inseln ist das abschieben
schwieriger erzürnte anwohner legen
selber hand an wie hier auf lesbos
wer das filmen will lebt gefährlich
auch erdogans videoblogger sorgen für
nachschub an hässlichen bildern aus der
egs bilder die uns merkels
flüchtlingspolitik 2015 ersparen wollte
jetzt tobt der kampf um die
deutungshoheit und die flüchtlinge sind
die opfer paul signac
cdu-generalsekretär hat sie mir sinn
dass die bilder die wir 2015 nicht
ertragen konnten
das sind die bilder die wir auch heute
nicht ertragen und man diskutiert dann
gleich über diese bilder aber der
innenminister hat recht wenn er sagt
wenn diese eu-außengrenze jetzt nicht
hält dann ist das etwas was die ganze
europäische union verändern wird wir
brauchen humanität wir brauchen aber
auch ordnung und dazu gehört eine
sichere eu außengrenzen und damit ist
das prinzip der menschlichkeit dem
prinzip der abschottung gewicht nein
überhaupt nicht aber sehen sie wir haben
jetzt eine situation an der
griechisch-türkischen grenze die vor
einigen wochen noch nicht da aber sie
ist verursacht worden weil der türkische
präsident gesagt hat die grenze ist
geöffnet ihr könnt alle gehen und
dadurch ist diese lage dort entstanden
und deswegen müssen wir alles verhindern
was jetzt noch den eindruck erwecken
könnte das die menschen in die
europäische union einreisen können und
am besten dann noch nach deutschland
kommen können wir brauchen jetzt wieder
die belebung dessen was wir mit der
türkei vereinbart haben nämlich das eu
türkei abkommens dazu kommen wir noch
neben ihnen sitzt annalena baerbock
einer der zwei vorsitzenden von
bündnis90 die grünen vor der burg sie
wollen dass deutschland wenigstens 5000
der besonders schutzbedürftigen
flüchtlinge in griechenland aufnimmt
dieser antrag ist im bundestag gestern
abgelehnt worden
haben sie keine sorge dass das noch viel
mehr menschen hoffnung machen würde
wir müssen glaube ich den maßstab sehen
wir haben in der türkei fast vier
millionen geflüchtete menschen und eine
situation da wir gerade die bilder
gesehen auf den griechischen inseln also
innerhalb der europäischen
union wo die humanität mit füßen
getreten wird also wo kinder wo familien
wir haben es gerade gesehen von
selbsternannten bürgerwehren angegriffen
werden weil die polizei gar nicht mehr
präsent ist wo wir flüchtlingslager
haben die eigentlich für 3000 ausgelegt
waren wo über 10.000 menschen auch viele
kinder im schlamm im dreck im eiskalten
winter überwintern müssen und da haben
wir gesagt deutschland die europäische
union muss zu seinen zusagen stehen die
man vor jahren auch gegenüber
griechenland gegenüber
die menschen die auf diesen inseln schon
seit langen wohnen gemacht hatten dass
man immer wieder in kontingenten
geflüchtete abnimmt und ja deswegen
haben wir gestern im deutschen bundestag
eingebracht zumindest erst mal 5000
schutzbedürftig frauen kinder familien
zu übernehmen sowie das im übrigen
gestern auch im eu innenministerrat
andere länder andere innenminister
vorgeschlagen haben zum beispiel aus
luxemburg oder auch als portugal und ich
glaube deutschland sollte da auch seinen
beitrag leisten wenn wir gleich noch
drüber diskutieren waren die
islamwissenschaftlerin und publizistin
lamya kaddor
sie sind deutsche frau kaddor ihre
eltern stammen aus idlib aus der jetzt
noch und zuletzt umkämpften region in
syrien frage nach europa wie überrascht
dass die politik hier eigentlich sein
dass wieder tausende flüchtlinge vor
eben grenzen stehen ja nun mal gar nicht
ehrlich gesagt also ich bin etwas
irritiert über ihre aussage zu dass sie
gerade sagten und jetzt da wo sie an den
grenzen stehen wir wissen um gründung
noch ein bisschen wie kalkuliert seit
jahren und es ist kalkulierbar vor
jahren schon gewesen dass ich irgendwann
beschlossen werden würde
als letzte größere stadt dass irgendwann
eine fluchtbewegung einsetzen wird und
dass irgendwann diese menschen nicht
alle nur in der türkei bleiben wollen
und dass sie irgendwann alle nach europa
kommen wollen dazu eine sehr viele ein
großer teil
das heißt jetzt so überrascht zu tun und
fast ohnmächtig zu wirken jedenfalls im
moment wirkt die eu ziemlich und möchte
ich ehrlich gesagt oder vielleicht auch
unwillens je nachdem wie man sehen
möchte finde ich wiederum ziemlich
überraschend denn eigentlich war das
doch sehr absehbar dass das passieren
würde die personen die jetzt dort an der
grenze sind die kommen nicht ausübt die
meisten personen die jetzt an dieser
grenze sind kommen aus afghanistan und
dem irak das müssen sie ein bisschen
auseinander halten
diese personen sind noch nicht
an dieser grenze diese personen sind
jetzt da weil sie in den lagern waren
und der präsident gesagt hat geht an die
grenze ist offen und er spielt ein spiel
mit den menschen schon in der 37
machen wir uns doch die zur
entschuldigung auf griechischen inseln
sitzen 42.000 menschen fest und die
sitzen dort nicht auf die person und
jetzt an der grenze sind nicht die
personen auf die postulierte personen
die frau berbalk und viele andere
deutsche übrigens viele kommunen die
sich dazu bereit erklären holen wollte
sind nicht die 13.000 erdogan geschickt
hat mit bussen das sind diejenigen die
auf den griechischen inseln ausharren
die stellen dort asylanträge und
bekommen einen termin in eineinhalb
jahren hier hat diego versagt wenn herr
seehofer sagt unsere unsere eu
asylpolitik bricht zusammen die ist gar
nicht existent und das ist das was mich
ärgert und wenn ich noch einmal sagen
darf dass wir die lehren aus 2015 nicht
gezogen haben was sind die lehren aus
2015 die wahren wenn wir die syrer nicht
in syrien schützen machen sie sich auf
den weg in die nachbarländer
wenn sie in den nachbarländern keine
perspektiven haben weil sie nicht
ordentlich versorgt werden und weil die
kinder als analphabeten aufwachsen ohne
schulbesuch dann ziehen sie irgendwann
weiter und wenn wir sie dann noch nicht
mal per kontingent holen eine gewisse
zahl von menschen für die wir auch eine
verantwortung haben weil wir in diesen
krieg nichts ausrichten können dann
haben wir wirklich versagt und dann
macht sich eine million menschen dass es
damals passiert mittellos traumatisiert
auf den weg über die balkanroute nach
europa das darf sich nicht wiederholen
das ist der viel beschworene
kontrollverlust wenn wir kontrolle
zurückgewinnen wollen müssen wir es
gestalten und müssen zur sache
zurückkehren nach syrien
[Applaus]
kristin helberg nahost-experten sie
haben lange aus damaskus berichtet frau
herberg und haben uns hier schon mit
ihrer expertise geholfen bei uns ist und
auch ihnen wollen wir unbedingt in der
hunde begrüßen
gerald knaus vordenker politikberater
einer der miterfinder des türkei eu
deals dazu werden wir auf jeden fall
noch kommen heraus
die griechen wenn wir zu denen noch
einmal gehen bevor wir zu erdogan kommen
haben jetzt für einen monat die
asylanträge untersagt oder besser gesagt
das asylgesetz storniert für diesen
zeitraum ist das in ihren augen
tatsächlich einen dammbruch oder ist es
eigentlich symbolpolitik weil jeder
asylantrag in griechenland wenigstens
zwei jahre braucht er bearbeitet wurde
das ist leider beides hat praktisch
keiner der bedeutung
es wird den griechen nichts nützen
würden die leute die jetzt ankommen wie
schon gesagt warten jahre auf einen
asylantrag es gibt hunderttausend
beinahe unbearbeitete asylanträge die
griechische asylbehörde kann im jahr
35.000 bearbeiten und es sind 42.000
menschen auf den inseln
also es nützt griechenland überhaupt
nichts das zu tun aber als signal an die
welt als signal dass die europäische
union jetzt in so einem so einer furcht
lebt dass sie das recht auf asyl was
nicht mal donald trump bis jetzt gewagt
hat oder nicht geschafft hat an der
grenze zu mexiko einfach aus setzt in
dem moment in dem eine zahl von menschen
an die grenzen kommt obwohl es uns gar
nichts nützt praktisch und es war nicht
oder griechenland ungarn hat das gleiche
gemacht einige stunden vorher und ungarn
nach dem letzten jahr weniger 600
asylanträge das recht auf asyl steht in
den europäischen verträgen das steht in
den in der kombi flüchtlingskonvention
unterstehe den eu gesetzen in
verordnungen richtlinien und ein
grundrecht dieser art so einfach
aufzuheben ist extrem gefährlich nicht
nur für flüchtlinge sondern für den
rechtsstaat
als nächstes wird die redefreiheit
aufgehoben und wer die kommission als
hüter der verträge müsste eigentlich
sofort einschreiten und sagen wir wollen
auch grenzkontrollen wir brauchen
kontrollen
und es gibt wege die grenzen zu
kontrollieren wir haben sie in den
letzten jahren gesehen aber grundrechte
so auszusetzen ist gefährlich ist extrem
gefährlich weil wie gesagt wo ist die
grenze und wenn europa wo die
flüchtlingskonvention 51 auf den lehren
des zweiten weltkriegs basierend
verabschiedet wurde sich davon
verabschiedet in einer welt wo ohnehin
schon viel zu viele autoritäre herrscher
gar nichts von internationalen recht
halten
dann verschwindet das dann stirbt die
flüchtlingskonvention und er trinkt den
marita dem fluss zur türkei oder in der
ägäis
[Applaus]
die neue kommissionspräsidentin ursula
von der leyen das überhaupt nicht
kritisiert sondern sie hat gesagt
griechenland sei europas schild dass
jetzt die stellung hält führen wir einen
kampf gegen die wir führen keinen kampf
aber wir brauchen noch mal wir brauchen
humanität und wir brauchen auch ordnung
wir werden ja die dinge von ihnen gerade
beschrieben etwas durcheinander gebracht
von verschiedenen seiten damit es dann
am ende auch ideologisch passt wenn sie
sagen dass deutschland nichts tut wir
haben im letzten jahrhundert 42.000
asylanträge in deutschland gehabt ein
großer teil davon erstanträge wir haben
seit 2005 fast zwei millionen menschen
hier aufgenommen also wenn es ein land
gibt was seine verantwortung
wahrgenommen hat dann ist es die
bundesrepublik deutschland gegenüber
flüchtlingen und migranten in der ganzen
welt es ist das erste
wenn man jetzt sagt man möchte 5000
personen von den griechischen inseln
nach deutschland bringen dann ist das
selbst ein sehr ehrenwertes ziel und ich
verstehe das auch das problem ist dass
gleichzeitig diejenigen dieses fordern
wie frau werber gleichzeitig wollen das
neue personen über die
türkisch-griechische grenze wieder in
die europäische union
also tun wir das haben kein abkommen mit
der türkei haben wir 5000 personen in
deutschland und gleichzeitig 50.000
personen wieder auf den griechischen
inseln und wir müssten doch aus 2015
gelernt haben dass wenn wir in diesen
test nicht bestehen ob ordnung auch an
den grenzen herrscht dass wir dann am
ende wird es nicht zu halten sein dass
wir keine grenzen im schengen raum haben
dass wir keine ganzen schengen-raum
haben heißt aber auch in dem nowitzkis
innenminister von horst seehofer dass
wir erst ordnung haben und dann
humanität es geht es geht zusammen aber
wir brauchen als erstes die sicherung
der außengrenzen der europäischen union
zweitens brauchen wir entsprechende
verhältnisse für diejenigen die
geflüchtet sind in der türkei das was
wir bisher gehabt haben und dann müssen
wir über die situation in griechenland
sprechen aber sie können nur über die
frage auf der verteilung sprechen denn
der europäischen union wenn sie nicht
gleichzeitig fordern das unbegrenzt neue
flüchtlinge in die europäische
frage eine frage noch mal zurück wenn
jetzt der schleswig-holsteinische
ministerpräsident andere bürgermeister
und oberbürgermeister von städten hier
in deutschland und sogar 48 abgeordnete
der unionsfraktion sagen das ist
eigentlich kein schlechter gedanke wir
können flüchtlinge aufnehmen und wir
erklären uns bereit dazu
dann sind die alle schon schritt weiter
als ihn diese abgeordnete diese
erklärung diese persönliche erklärung
abgegeben haben wenn sie sich die
erklärung anschauen ich finde die sehr
gut dort ist auch beispielsweise ganz
klar geschrieben dass man eben diese
sicherung der außengrenzen braucht man
braucht diese vereinbarung mit der
türkei
und erst dann steht in der persönlichen
erklärung und das ist absolut richtig
müssen wir darüber sprechen wie was kann
man eigentlich machen wir leisten jeden
tag als deutschland unseren beitrag und
wenn jetzt kommunen bürgermeister hin
kommen und sagen wir sind bereit
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen halte ich dass
ich freue mich dass die
hilfsbereitschaft zuerst aber
ehrlicherweise diese kommunen sind ja
nicht bereit auf dauer auch die lasten
zu tragen die damit verbunden sind keine
dieser länder keine dieser kommunen das
ist eine frage des bundes der bund steht
dafür gerade und deswegen wenn unser
land kommt ist doch nicht die
angelegenheit von kommunalpolitik
sondern des bundes und der
bundestagsabgeordneten ich will ihnen
das nehme ich an einen ganz einfachen
beispiel sagen
sie nehmen jetzt das positivbeispiel
eine kommune sagt wir haben noch
kapazitäten also sagen sie dann
vielleicht ja
dann schicken wir die flüchtlinge
dorthin sagen wir denn wenn eine kommune
sagt wir wollen keine flüchtlinge mehr
haben sagen wir dann das ist in ordnung
also gibt es keine flüchtlinge mehr
nein auch dann entscheidet der bund
menschen werden in deutschland verteilt
die das recht haben hierzubleiben
deswegen zeigt eben dieses umgekehrte
beispiel das ist nicht nur aufgabe von
kommunalpolitikern zu entscheiden wenn
man deutsch politikern oder
ministerpräsidenten dieses landes ist
vorbei wir greifen das stichwort auf
ordnung für ordnung ist zu sorgen eine
ganz praktische frage auf dem festland
griechischen festland kann man
sicherlich mit polizei und auch mit
frontex zäune ziehen und eine grenze
schützen
wie macht man das auf dem meer wie macht
man das in der ägäis übers meer kann man
nicht zu entspannen
das stimmt und deswegen gehört dass
beides zueinander zusammen man kann ist
es aus meiner sicht eine illusion zu
sagen wir schaffen erstmal ordnung und
dann kümmern wir uns um die humanität
weil das gehört beides hand in hand
zusammen wenn man jetzt mit tränengas
auf kinder aus familien schießt dann
kreiert das doch erst chaos da sind doch
keine geordneten strukturen sondern
geordnete strukturen und das ist auch
unser vorschlag deswegen eigentlich sie
wissen das ja aus meiner sicht sehr
genau
gerade wenn dann kontingente hat
kontingente heiß ja eben nicht alle
gehen auf eine grenze zu umgehen da
irgendwie selber durch oder über
stacheldrahtzäune oder übers meer
sondern kontingente bedeutet seißen
griechische inseln oder sei es aus der
türkei das uhren hcr also das
flüchtlingshilfswerk der vereinten
nationen eine sehr geordnete
organisation
das erklärt was sind die besonders
schutzbedürftigsten weil die schaffens
meistens ja überhaupt gar nicht mit
eigener kraft an die grenze zu kommen
denen stellen wir eine auswahl zusammen
melden dass den europäischen staaten
damit die sich darauf vorbereiten können
deswegen ist das mittel der kontingente
ein sehr geordnetes verfahren und auf
der anderen seite muss man natürlich und
ich glaube in dieser runde das stellt
niemand infrage muss man dafür sagen
wenn man gemeinsame europäische
außengrenze hat damit man sich in europa
frei bewegen kann dass wir an der
außengrenze natürlich grenzkontrollen
haben das ist das wesen einer grenze
dass sie kontrolliert wird aber das
wesen einer grenze nach dem völkerrecht
da bin ich ganz bei herrn klaus ist auch
eine grenze
hat das hat der europäische gerichtshof
für menschenrechte grad noch einmal
unterstrichen
legale zugangswege wo menschen hinkommen
können und dann auf basis der genfer
flüchtlingskonvention ein treffer darf
er sich tatsächlich und darum geht's in
diesem tag wahnsinnig viel gesprochen
worden wir erinnern uns an die berühmten
hotspots und an die berühmten anker
zentren frage nochmal an herrn klaus
vier jahre zeit war herr klaus was hat
die eu in diesen vier jahren eigentlich
geschafft außer die zäune ein bisschen
höher zu machen es gibt einen sehr
großen erfolg und es gibt ein
katastrophales versagen der große erfolg
war dass die eu und zwar solidarisch
also alle mitglieder haben gemeinsam
bezahlt 6 milliarden an die türken für
flüchtlinge in der türkei damit den
680.000 kinder in die schulen die hälfte
aller schüler in der türkei bekommen
sozialhilfe gleich mal genau und
strichen das heißt das ergebnis war die
syrer sind nicht im boot gestiegen und
der migrationsdruck auf griechenland war
jetzt dreieinhalb jahre sehr niedrig das
ergebnis war und jetzt komme ich zum
versagen
das ist absolut möglich gewesen wäre
wenn im jahr 2017 in einem halben jahr
9000 leute auf die inseln kommen im jahr
2018 im ganzen jahr 30.000 diese
menschen menschenwürdig zu versorgen
jetzt sind 1000 unbekannte jugendliche
nur in lesbos da ist eine meningitis
epidemie
die leute haben einen schaden fürs leben
wir müssen die rausholen
das haben wir nicht gemacht wir haben es
nicht geschafft schnelle verfahren zu
machen als die zahlen niedrig waren bei
24 42.000 wir jetzt geht das nicht mehr
die müssen sich aufs festland bringen
und das dritte war wir haben etwas
erfolgreich gemacht um sehe ich in der
debatte eigentlich eine möglichkeit nach
vorn zu kommen wo ganz viele deutsche
mit gehen könnten
wir hatten schon einmal diese umsiedlung
aus griechenland 217 216 haben wir 22
1000 menschen einem geordneten verfahren
nach irland nach finnland und zwar
schutzbedürftige allerdings muss ich
dazu sagen der damalige griechische
migrationsminister von einer linken
regierung serena hat mir gesagt vor dem
youtube kommen wenn er war eigentlich
gegen die umsiedlung dass griechenland
vor dem abkommen weil er angst hatte das
zeichen würde bedeuten dass 4
vier flüchtlinge kommen und einer wird
griechenland abgenommen und dann hat
kriegen ja noch mehr leute also wenn wir
beides zusammen denken ein neues
abkommen mit der türkei
menschenrechte menschenwürde gefällt es
auf den griechischen inseln schnelle
verfahren und dann den griechen klar
sagen ob für die kinder würde ich sagen
die müssen heute oder gestern von den
inseln
wir müssen sie in sichere
menschenwürdige orte bringen finnland
hat gerade angeboten 175 kinder zu
übernehmen
aus zypern und aus griechenland auf
deutsche größe hochgerechnet 405
millionen einwohner werden dass 3000
kinder
ich würde aber auch sagen es geht nicht
um symbolpolitik wir müssen alle kinder
von den inseln aufs festland bringen
griechenland hat viele orte wo man
kinder menschenwürdig unterbringen kann
gleichzeitig müssen wir den griechen
sagen es gibt eine gruppe von staaten
die in den nächsten wochen bereit ist in
einem geordneten verfahren mit uhren hcr
diese kinder die wir sowieso nicht in
die türkei zurückschicken haben die
griechen nie gemacht unbegleitete kinder
zurückgestellt die nehmen wir dann auf
aber als gesamtkonzept mit einer
strategie dass die zahl der leute die
auf die inseln kommen wieder fällt weil
wenn wir von den inseln leute nehmen und
wie im september oktober november jeden
monat 10.000 oder jetzt das war vor
erdogans aufkündigung des deals jetzt
womöglich 15 20.000 im monat kommen dann
ist die situation auf dem insel
schlechter und dann explodiert die
stimmung auch in griechenland wir können
beides wir können leute übernehmen wir
können dafür sorgen dass kinder nicht zu
leben das ist eine katastrophe wir
sollten uns aber ich glaube jeder hier
ist wir sollten das heute beenden
gleichzeitig müssen wir einen weg finden
dass die lage nicht schlimmer wird weil
immer mehr menschen ankommen